Émile a disparu depuis désormais plus de
deux semaines le hameau du haut Vernet
et c'est 30 habitations sont à nouveau
sillonnées par la gendarmerie car depuis
mardi matin et recherche de terrain du
petit Emile ont été relancés à l'aide de
drones ils survolent l'ensemble de la
commune à ce jour aucune piste
n'étaitquée s'est-il perdu a-t-il été
enlevé le petit garçon c'était
volatilisé le 8 juillet alors qu'il
jouait dans le jardin de la maison de
ses grands-parents dans un village de
125 habitants ces nouvelles fouilles
n'ont pas de durée prédéfinie tout
dépend de l'avancée des recherches
explique la gendarmerie contacté par Le
Figaro autre nouveauté les gendarmes ont
également fait appel à des chiens
spécialisés dans la recherche de restes
humains il s'agit de déterminer si l'on
a ou pas un cadavre sur la commune du
haut Vernet le but est de fermer cette
porte précise une source proche du
dossier le flair de sa canidés est
spécialement entraîné à repérer les
odeurs émanant de corps mort ils te font
le troisième groupe de chiens intervenir
sur le terrain à la recherche d'Emile
après la briatine au fil spécialisée
dans le pistage des personnes vivantes
portées disparues et les chiens de
Saint-Hubert dotés d'un odorat
extrêmement fin et 30 maisons du haut
Vernet ont été passées au crible et tous
les véhicules visités de même 97
hectares de champs de bois ou de terrain
escarpés ont été minutieusement
inspectés mais pour le moment le mystère
reste complet toutes les pistes restent
envisagées aucune n'étant exclu ni
privilégié à souligner à plusieurs
reprises le procureur
[Musique]